6 25 on your wednesday morning the big
squeeze is getting shiftier ahead of
more bridge demolitions part of the
ongoing 40 million dollar i-515 viaduct
rehabilitation project that we like to
call the big squeeze a bunch of lane
restrictions ramp closures been going on
all week and they will continue the rest
of the week they are all on ndot's
website the i515project.com
but the bigger part of the story is
monday's demolition of the northbound 95
515 bridge over eastern that's going to
mean a nine-day closure of eastern under
the freeway now southbound drivers in 95
well you're already using the
reconstructed lanes from last year's
demolition of that part of the freeway
bridge and if that experience is any
indication the upcoming demolition and
restrictions should go fairly smoothly
that includes suggested detours for both
north and southbound travel while
eastern is closed we're talking about
bonanza and or stuart over to maryland
parkway with local business access on
eastern still open and all of this
information and all of our stories are
on our 8newsnow.com website when you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
something driving